nous avons assis dans vos étudiants
l'air chaud de la pupille monte
prend la zone euro avec l'amazone
être à travers cette hotte
puis ajouté au gros tuyau
ramassé et avec le ventilateur après
expédier à l'extérieur
l'appareil ser 2s ne change rien à cela
problème donc l'ambiance en allemand
l'école devient de plus en plus précaire
Le nombre de cas augmente et c'est naturel
c'est pourquoi c'est pareil dans nos écoles
nous serions heureux si nous avions cela très bientôt
aurait alors des systèmes de ventilation partout
nous pourrions bien sûr aussi considérablement
enseigner plus détendu
c'est comme ça que tout dans la vie doit être
sois simple ça ne doit pas être si cher
et puis tu as la chance
ce qui est mis en œuvre et c'est exactement cela
grand chose à propos de ce système et surtout
les choses c'est donc c'est aussi dans le
pensée future
aussi à l'avenir le co2
réduire l'équilibre et puis c'est un appareil
pas seulement pour la pandémie
est acheté mais aussi définitivement
peut rester installé dans les chambres